[Music]  my name's Courtney hadwin and thirteen  I'm just scared to go onstage social  anxiety might have played Courtney  before her America's Got Talent audition  I'm kind of crying and sickened in my  own path but when she took the stage her  soulful performance was a shocking  surprise Courtney was a natural her  powerful voice and dance moves brought  the audience and judges to their feet  Howie Mandel was especially moved the  only thing I can do for you young lady  is give you host Tyra Banks was with a  visibly emotional Courtney right after  her big moment you thought you were  gonna get a red buzzer like get sent  home  and that complete opposite happens  that's my golden buzzer  [Applause]  [Music]